hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
obscurity ok we just ran into a monster
that was weird as [ __ ] I think the
technical term weird as [ __ ] a woth ok
so we need to go somewhere the padlock
is warm can I just know by cannot I need
to find something in my sanity is not
doing well ok came through here good oh
great that fantastic I love that gotta
go where the monster came from seriously
my sanity is not doing good need a
little some some as a pick-me-up if you
know what I mean ok alright vision has
cleared my brain is not so scram no my
brain is just as scrambled as before but
I'm just I stopped being a [ __ ] I
stopped being giant [ __ ] about it
toughened up yes knew there was hidden
oil I could smell it smells from my
larvae I don't know what accent I'm
doing I'm not good at accents I should
stop trying or I should just try Carter
what the [ __ ] are you ah
peste my brain was already a little bit
red you didn't need to be a douche oh
now my visions gone totally 100% wobbly
oh no I've gone cross-eyed I knew that
was gonna be something why did I even
let it get me why did I let it get me I
don't know I'm a fool to myself aha
if I could just concentrate and stop
being drunk for two seconds a large oil
potion Oh cute oh yes let me just stand
in the light until my sanity recuperates
here to stand right on the candle have
the candle burn my ass into shape
so that I stop being such giant [ __ ]
stop being pissy about it we're good now
as we better now we are not we are still
giant [ __ ] but we as can least move
well in here I don't know what accent
I'm doing I really don't but I remember
a long time ago and I first started I
did lots of accents I did the Swedish
accent too many times and I ed was great
laughs all around and everybody enjoyed
it Beibei my three this accent is a mix
of Canadian Norwegian and Swedish just
save Roberta News what I'm going on the
beta that would be a cute hiding place
here right whatever I don't even know
what I'm going for why am I here there's
a pot of acid but I don't have anything
to add grab the acid I am assuming the
acid is going to be required to wear the
padlock but I don't have anything to
call it in so I'm just gonna keep
wandering the halls forever padlock is
in good condition good taking you with
me
ha ha ha oh ha ha ha
this wall doesn't look sturdy I can
probably find a tool in the morgue to
break through why not a chair chairs are
so damn useless what a pile of pish posh
whoo come on whoo dude of a chair oh
don't you go down her habits I will snap
your [ __ ] wings up like hey you like
at all
yeah grab my god I don't know oh do here
wait a gum room for a my class sure I
think oh oh not like that thing I do not
like that thing I do not it is wrong the
more ways than one
is it wrong it's not supposed to be that
low I think that really the only thing
that I don't like about is I so low to
the ground it's just disconcerting it it
to psycho take it away did I close the
door good
I really don't like that thing it's just
where all the other monsters are
humanoid they walk somewhat like humans
that thing that thing was not at all
even a little bit and the hissing does
not help what if you come in here I will
oh I'll Jack slap you
I will oh okay the music yay yay let me
do a save and exit so they don't lose
progress
I don't like I don't like that thing do
not I do not I don't I don't I don't
like it okay I need to get some acid
yeah man okay I need to get some acid
get the hell out of here okay so
apparently I don't need no way not this
way
Boosh um I don't need to worry about any
locks that are in good condition
oh you're so wrong you're so wrong it's
w is buzzin gonna help me are so bud hi
Roman where are those wannabe I'm so
bored
I don't know how it's not automatically
busting in here but man I just don't
like that thing don't like that thing
that's low and quicken oh come on be
good music for once be good to me it
burst through that thing I don't know
why what do I need this fourth for the
worn padlock that's right oh oh man at
least they're giving me plenty of oil
that's all I can be thankful for
hmm okay so I need to get through the
other side in order to find something
that can break through the wall I'm
guessing thought I heard something
leave that gate open case I need to run
alright this looks good
I like this shut up
shut up go to hell already this game
automatically made me paranoid about
your closet do you think it is I don't
know I've never seen anything like it
where did you find this my crew and I
found it in the mines I was just laying
there all right well I'll run some tests
and see if I can get any results in the
meantime you should go back and see if
you can find one alive this could
potentially be a huge discovery no how
about you don't do that
because these things are evil yesterday
afternoon one of my good friends came in
with the corpse of the creature I'd
never seen before
he claims he and his crew found it in
the mines for approximately the past 12
hours I've been examining it in
performing tests this is a huge
discovery
however I think I should head home soon
Clarissa has been urging me to spend
more time with Simon and Elizabeth after
all I haven't been much of a father to
them lately something weird is going on
though when I cut cut open the corpse to
examine its organs it seemed to move
slightly maybe it was just my
imagination as I don't see how it could
possibly be alive it has no pulse and
isn't responding to any external stimuli
I'm going to lock the corpse up in a
storage closet for the night just to be
safe
oh pass
[ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] don't tell me
that this is the storage closet do not
juice oh you mother
Jesus oh [ __ ] son of a monkey Nutter ah
I knew it I know it done I knew it I'm
[ __ ] knew it I [ __ ] knew you piece
of [ __ ]
you son of a [ __ ] good Tigger look does
open [ __ ] Jesus your piece of crap son
of a mother fired I knew it I knew it
same type of scare liar were lining up
as before I knew it
Sam hell I bid son of a [ __ ] please
things you can sneak up on me no I'm too
smart too smart too handsome and too
strong screwed chair you're no good to
me okay I'm out yay hey look is
convenient boxes stocked up here
everything seems to be connected to the
mines I may be able to find answers down
there I should also investigate my
father's safe why don't I get the hell
out of town
that would be a good idea this is a bad
idea that good idea play click good idea
click click bad idea click click good
idea go out of town and forget this
place
click click bad idea stay in town
investigate these weird monsters they
can't be that bad
from the Animaniacs never mind
I always get aggravated that is the
decision-making of these heroes of
course if they didn't go there wouldn't
be a game but if there been I wouldn't
have to jump get jumpscared
I wouldn't I wouldn't have to it
wouldn't have to happen it doesn't have
to happen you can live a sensible life
as a lawyer go bang a couple prostitutes
I don't care just relieve your stress
some other way okay I don't have
everything to go into the elevator in
the mines just yet but I will soon okay
so let me just figure out the puzzle but
before I do I thought that was a body
let me just do a quick save and exit
here to make sure that my game does not
crash it hasn't yet but I'm just I don't
want to tempt fate okay so I had a note
that said exactly what I needed to do in
order to get out of here get out of here
okay no that's not it safe combination
for less than the number of houses in
the military let's count them
uno dos tres cuatro Cinco J or sexy a so
three one two three four five six seven
one one two three four five six seven
okay yeah seven not not counting me in
okay that's seven so the first one is
three the first one is three then five
so three five third digit is 2 right at
my house so three five the barrels -
what if someone moved a barrel might be
was this a big old rock that's what that
is okay three five I'm just guessing two
barrels so okay three five two
three five two number rooms available to
you I don't know that maybe it wasn't
one of the notes three five two I think
it's three I think there were three
rooms upstairs but I'm not exactly sure
either way it's either three or four
three five two three three five two
three back home sweet okay so the
mechanism was under the bed which I can
now move uh Hera's okay how much I move
your son above them there we go what
that come on get out of there
you stupid bread gah your stupid bad
there we go thank you
come on okay three five two three ah
Pass three five two four mother of
fudger to the right of his house I'm
thinking that might be the wrong one
okay let's try three five two six three
five two five okay so to the right of
the house what does that mean that could
mean anything that could mean literally
anything three five three three three
five three saw no I'm gonna be here
forever so I am actually all out of time
so I'm gonna figure this out in the
break so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for videos
that I've done and as always I will see
Oh in the next video by
Oh
Moctar
Oh
you